queen à part à l'automne si ces
miliciens au long du puits
alors cette semaine encore une fois en
direct de mon petit coin de distance
sociale
cependant avec toujours la communauté
très proche de mon coeur et c'est pour
ça que cette semaine je vais vous
suggérez mon panier cultuelle des
premières nations des premiers peuples
pour pouvoir passer à travers la
distanciation sociale finalement à la
maison obligatoire mais sans
nécessairement avoir à se distancier de
la bonne culture parce que si on veut de
la culture des premières nations et les
cultures des communautés inuit
il faut en consommer pour qu'on puisse
en faire offrir cependant comme un peu
le panier bleus nous à évita consommer
local à consommer québécois mais des
fois c'est rare il est difficile d'avoir
des suggestions qui viennent des
premières nations ou des communautés
inuites parce que on n'utilise pas les
mêmes chemins pour se diffuser
donc je veux partager cette semaine dans
plusieurs formes d'art des suggestions
culturel que vous pourriez essayer de
découvrir en famille
cette semaine j'ai beaucoup parlé de la
danse de porc dernièrement donc je vous
invite à continuer à suivre le mot clic
de sochaux destin du port le port de
distanciation social pour vous vous
inspirez pouvoir des danses qui viennent
de plusieurs communautés
mais pour elle un peu plus de l'avant je
vous invite aussi à explorer par exemple
les libraires point c'est parce que pour
encourager des libraires québécois des
libraires qui nous avons aussi des
livres en français
il faut aussi se dire qu'on vient des
libraires assez spécialisés au québec
dont la librairie année novak qui offre
une très grosse diversité de produits
littéraire des premiers peuples alors
d'un peu partout du nord ou au sud vous
pouvez trouver des textes d'ailleurs
j'ai commandé justement le livre comme
de michel jean qui vient de sortir et
que j'ai très hâte de lire alors ça me
permet de consommer à distance sociale
très sécuritaire des livres des
communautés autochtones
alors ça c'est pour la littérature et
quand je pense à avize
elle je pensais à caroline monnaie qui
dernièrement fait partie de l'accord qui
ont reçu une bourse du prix soba plutôt
que d'offrir un prix à un artiste
la bourse a décidé de distribuer vu les
conditions sociales et et la paire de
diffusion que beaucoup d'artistes vont
avoir dans les prochaines semaines
d'offrir un prix et donc elle a reçu un
prix à 25 mille dollars
et je pense que ce qu'il faut pas
négliger c'est que les artistes visuels
beaucoup de leur diffusion
se fondant la présence dans les galeries
donc c'est un peu un possible
présentement mais si vous allez sur
caroline monnaie.ca vous allez pouvoir
explorer un peu ce qu'elle fait vous en
inspirer pour pouvoir ensuite quand on
pourra enfin sortir de chez nous allez
visiter les galeries qui la diffuse
alors n'hésitez pas carole est une
monnaie pour essayer elle va bientôt
être partout sur les plateformes locales
a donc profité encore quand c'est proche
de chez vous ensuite on va penser
télévision télévision pourquoi je pense
à la télévision c'est qu'on pense
beaucoup à ptn et qui est une des
premières chaînes télévisuelles pour les
communautés autochtones mais elle a
forci présentement une application et
pour les prochaines semaines jusqu'à la
fin du mois de mai et bien toute la
programmation jeunesse est un frère est
offerte gratuitement sur leur
application donc ça c'est un bon une
bonne manière de pouvoir introduire la
culture des premières nations à vos
jeunes n'hésitaient pas avec la
télévision n'hésitez pas non plus pour
ce qui est de la musique à utiliser
facebook live parce que centrale invités
du saguenay offre une programmation
énorme jusqu'à la fin du mois de juillet
en diffusant sur leur page facebook
des lives string les vendredis soirs
d'artistes musicaux et de toutes sortes
de formes bas sur leurs pages donc on va
voir
natasha khan ap photo ten on va voir ça
miaule l'on a vu gilbert qui tâche ou
une vue ni mon canapé on va voir matthew
il ya énormément d'artistes
dolor qui vont être diffusés sur leur
page facebook tous les vendredis jusqu'à
la fin juillet c'est une manière
d'explorer la musique des programmations
alors on a fait des ratures on a fait or
visuels musique télévision cinéma cinéma
pourquoi parce que je pense au nouveau
film de jeff barnaby qui s'en est
peut-être pas pour tout le monde parce
que c'est blake wharton
c'est un film de zombies assez gore et
est assez dans le style de films de
zombies mais qui a dû retarder justement
sa première parce qu'elle elle est
arrivée en prêt dans le début de la
pandémie de covin donc ils ont retardé
et le 28 avril
elle sera disponible sur itunes et aussi
sur plusieurs plateformes de streaming
payant mais ça vaut la peine
d'encourager le cinéma des premières
nations surtout quand il peut rentrer
dans ton salon
et si on veut se permettre une soirée
cinéma et inspirante et bien là j'avais
suggéré aussi la carrière colloque qui
en fait attend à droite de face
maintenant à temps a rejoint le coureur
rapide
un film extraordinaire qui se posent en
virant nord et qui peut nous relativiser
par rapport à la sensation du temps qui
passe
quand j'ai vu cela c'était la première
fois que j'ai dit on a compris comment
interpréter le temps chez les
communautés autochtones parce que
souvent c'est pas la même sensation
qu'ils aient vécu dans le cinéma
nord-américaines qui se passe beaucoup
plus rythmé que dans notre cinéma nous
donc cinéma littérature musique
on a aussi la jument de la télévision
mais tout cet ensemble ne pourrait pas
exister si on ne pensait pas aussi à la
langue est présentement la distance
sociale nous permet de prendre le temps
de perfectionner notre connaissance de
la langue qu'elles soient minimes où
qu'elles soient grandes donc profiter
aussi des sites web des institutions
culturelles et là je pense à tshakapesh
point c'est dur parce que je pense bien
sûr malanga mois linou moines et il
offre n
mes mains de produits culturels de
vidéos mais aussi d'outils pour pouvoir
apprendre la langue
alors si c'est un moment pour qu'on peut
se donner en ce moment dans sept ans
estime y est de pouvoir apprendre ou
réapprendre sa langue
alors vous voyez mon panier déborde
culturellement et j'espère qu'il va vous
inspirer j'espère sincèrement que vous
allez nous suggérer dans les
commentaires vos produit culturel
autochtone qui vous recommande à tout le
monde et ce n'est pas non plus à
partager cette vidéo et je vous souhaite
une belle semaine